[Music]
[Applause]
we have reached the end of the hour but
I have one more uplifting story to share
this is what I'm liking
a baby calf in Australia is bringing
smiles to people worldwide and that is
because he was born with a literal smile
on his coat take a look
smiley face on the bull cap that's
incredible of course there was only
all of him happy even better Happy was
sold for charity and will live out his
days on a farm we have happy on the line
from Australia along with his new owner
of farm World Craig watching on seven
Bravo oh my God this is amazing
oh my gosh so did I kill him it's
unbelievable even when you see it live
in prison okay so this was a win-win for
everybody especially happy right a
hundred percent Kelly he's uh as you can
see got a beautiful happy smiling face
on his torso he was born down in
southeast uh Australia in Victoria and
the reality is uh you know we we kind of
stepped in once they took a photo and it
went a bit viral on them and their
farmers and they uh they didn't kind of
want the media attention but we run a
big major event space here and a big
event called Farm world every year happy
was the star of the show and uh we got
300 acres of beautiful green Rolling
Hills in gippsland for him to play with
and to to munch on so he's going to have
a wonderful life for many years to come
as our mascot um and this these these
markings on his torso are just going to
grow with him and get get stronger and
stronger so uh yeah really pleased to
have you oh my gosh he's beautiful and
happy helped raise money for the
hospital there right yeah he did so so
Megan and Barry
um basically donated him to us and we
made a donation to the local hospital
for 10 000 Australian dollars US seven
thousand dollars uh to be able to host
uh Happy on the property for the next 20
25 years that's how long that will go
and the local hospital picked up a
fantastic donation for happy and uh so
it's a win-win for everybody happy gets
a beautiful life on the green rolling
pastures of gippsland uh Megan and Barry
have made a fantastic donation with our
support as ladder Park and farm World
our big event and uh the hospital gets
to enjoy the the donation and put uh put
that money to Great use Megan and
Barry's kids were were born at the
hospital and it really really supports
our agricultural Community here in in
Victoria in gippsland wow it really is a
win-win all because happy was just born
with that little smiley face it's so
amazing thank you so much Craig thank
you happy
[Applause]
right now
and that's not all our season long
partner pilot pin makers of G2 the go-to
pin of the Kelly Clarkson show love how
happy is raising money to help your
local hospital and they want to pitch in
as well so they're going to be riding
the West Gibson land Health Care Group a
check for a thousand dollars
oh that's awesome
thank you you got so much for joining us
and thank you to all our guests this
hour Sterling K Brown Jaren Lewis and
Tanya Holland Malachi Miranda and Craig
shout out to this little sister malcast
Houston Nevada joined us today as well
have a happy day y'all and if it's not
try and changing
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
guys I'm going home
[Music]